let's go next to okay let's go to the
eight three one area code caller from
eight three one who's there
I couldn't hear your name and we can
barely hear you so let's see what we can
do about either your connection or your
phone or something okay that's a little
better what was your name Jared Jared
okay go ahead
yeah I'm just curious on what your
specific policies or curbing gun
violence would be okay so we've done a
bunch of long-form pieces into this
there's a bunch of different approaches
that we need to take we need to have
100% universal background checks just
period if a gun is transacted in any way
that needs to go through the exact same
process no matter where where it's
happening we should be reducing the ease
with which high-capacity magazines can
be sold there are a lot of shootings
that would still happen with more
difficult access to high-capacity
magazines but would be far less damaging
we need to re-examine which guns should
and shouldn't be readily available to
the public we need gun insurance we
should have much stricter psychological
evaluation before someone's going to own
a firearm I mean there's a lot of
different things that can that can be
and should be done so I guess so would
you be four so the semi-automatic issue
I feel like is a little bit of a red
herring in the sense that people
sometimes hear semi-automatic and they
imagine something that is an automatic
weapon so I think I it's a completely
reasonable conversation to have I don't
think it's the top priority because I
think that there are much there's much
lower hanging fruit than semi-automatic
weapons so I'm not ready to take the
position that semi-automatic weapons
should be banned I think there's a whole
bunch of other stuff that would be
easier to do and
would be more effective and would be
lower hanging fruit that I would do
focus on first yeah if I could get in
one more do you think that the Democrats
should run on universal health care as a
bargaining chip to fall back to a public
public option or do you believe the
Medicare for all is the correct solution
right well so okay your question is a
pragmatic one because whether they run
on it because that's what they want or
they run on it because they want to
negotiate to something else they have to
run on it in a serious manner now you
can't say we're gonna run on this but we
really don't mean it we want to use it
as a way to negotiate a public option
like that's how you lose right so right
now they just need to run on what they
think is right um I believe that what is
right is some kind of single-payer
medicare-for-all or other universal
coverage options that I've seen employed
successfully in different countries even
if it's a bargaining chip you don't say
that now you just run on what you think
the policy should be and later if
someone wants to offer you something in
a negotiation then you evaluate it when
you get to that point yeah I mean I'm
I'm just curious to like me specifically
I know that it's a popular talking point
but I haven't actually seen a plan for
being able to pay for it oh you just
haven't looked there's and there's
countless plans a checkout Gerald
Friedman from the University of
Massachusetts there's a whole bunch of
plan so just look them up I'm gonna let
you go because I've got a bunch of
people holding here that I want to get
to